OVER THE DEAD BODIES OF THEIR
LOVED ONES.
ACCORDING TO OFFICIALS THERE,
THE DEATH TOLL NOW TOPS 3,600
AND COUNTING, MORE THAN 1,000
ARE STILL MISSING.
THE GOVERNMENT ESTIMATES THAT
TWO MILLION PEOPLE ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED OF FOOD.
TWO MILLION.
DESPITE THE OBSTACLES AND CLEAR
DIFFICULTIES THE GOVERNMENT IS
HAVING IN GETTING RELIEF TO
THOSE WHO NEED IT, SOME IN THE
PHILIPPINE MEDIA WOULD RATHER
FOCUS ON THE GOVERNMENT'S IMAGE.
A RADIO HOST IN THE PHILIPPINES
WHO JUST HAPPENS TO BE MARRIED
TO THE COUNTRY'S INTERIOR
SECRETARY ACCUSED OUR OWN
ANDERSON COOPER OF COMING ON
"THE LEAD" CLAIMING HE SAW NO
PRESENCE OF THE PHILIPPINE
GOVERNMENT ON THE GROUND IN
TACLOBAN.
ONLY PROBLEM IS ANDERSON NEVER
SAID THAT.
ANDERSON COOPER JOINS US NOW
LIVE FROM THE PHILIPPINE CAPITAL
OF MANILA.
WELCOME.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
ON TUESDAY, YOU DESCRIBED THE
CROWD AT THE CRIPPLED TACLOBAN
AIRPORT, SURVIVORS HUDDLED
THERE, YOU EXPRESSED SURPRISE
THE GOVERNMENT HADN'T GOTTEN A
BETTER HANDLE ON THE SITUATION
BUT YOU NEVER SAID THERE WAS NO
PHILIPPINE GOVERNMENT PRESENCE
ON THE GROUND.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THIS
BIZARRE, INACCURATE ATTACK?
WHY DO YOU THINK SHE SAID THAT?
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, I'M NOT
REALLY CLEAR.
I DON'T KNOW WHO THIS PERSON IS.
I KNOW SHE'S THE WIFE OF THE,
YOU KNOW, OF THE INTERIOR
MINISTER WHO I GUESS ALSO WAS
UNDER THE IMPRESSION THAT I SAID
THIS BECAUSE HE CAME LOOKING FOR
ME WHEN I WAS ON THE GROUND IN
TACLOBAN.
BUT I DON'T REALLY KNOW.
SHE'S SOME SORT OF RADIO HOST OR
SOMETHING AND THIS IS WHAT SHE
SAID.
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, HAVING BEEN
ON THE GROUND THERE, WE WERE
REPORTING WHAT WE WERE SEEING
AND OF COURSE, THERE'S PLENTY OF
PHILIPPINE MILITARY AND POLICE
PRESENCE AT THE AIRPORT AND AT
ROADBLOCKS.
ONE OF THE THINGS I WAS SAYING
IS THAT OUT IN THE FIELD, EVEN
HALF A BLOCK AWAY OR HALF A MILE
AWAY FROM THE AIRPORT, WHERE
PEOPLE'S BODIES ARE LAYING OUT,
WHERE FAMILIES ARE SEARCHING FOR
THEIR LOST LOVED ONES, THEY HAVE
SEEN NO HELP.
MOTHERS WHO ARE SEARCHING FOR
THEIR DEAD KIDS HAVE GOTTEN NO
HELP IN THAT SEARCH FROM RESCUE
WORKERS, ACCORDING TO ALL THE
MOTHERS I HAVE BEEN TALKING TO
WHO ARE THERE.
I HAVE BEEN GOING BACK DAY AFTER
DAY AFTER DAY TO CHECK IN ON IF
THEY HAVE BEEN GETTING ANY
ASSISTANCE TO TRY TO SEARCH FOR
THEIR LOST CHILDREN.
SO I WAS SAYING IN JAPAN, WE SAW
MILITARY SOLDIERS, NATIONAL
DEFENSE SOLDIERS THE DAY AFTER
THE TSUNAMI GOING BLOCK BY
BLOCK, LOOKING THROUGH THE
WRECKAGE FOR BODIES OR ANYBODY
WHO MAY BE ALIVE.
I THINK POLITICS IS INVOLVED
WITH THIS.
I THINK THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS CONCERNED ABOUT CRITICISM,
THEY MIGHT BE GETTING.
LOCAL AUTHORITIES ARE POINTING
FINGERS AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS POINTING FINGERS AT LOCAL
AUTHORITIES.
BOTTOM LINE, THE ONLY THING THAT
MATTERS, THIS IS ALL KIND OF A
BIZARRE SIDE SHOW.
THE ONLY THING THAT MATTERS IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE GROUND.
AND IS AID GETTING TO PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT MOST.
CLEARLY, THERE HAVE BEEN, YOU
KNOW, BIG DELAYS, BIG LACK OF
ORGANIZATION ON THE PART OF THE
PHILIPPINE GOVERNMENT ON THE
GROUND THERE.
THAT IS STARTING TO GET BETTER.
THERE IS STARTING TO BE MORE
FOOD DISTRIBUTION BY THE WORLD
FOOD PROGRAM AND OTHERS, BUT
IT'S CERTAINLY BEEN FAR TOO LONG
AND TIME IS THE ENEMY OF PEOPLE
WHEN YOU'RE DESPERATE FOR WATER
AND FOOD AND MEDICAL ATTENTION.
>> ANDERSON, REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THE GOVERNMENT MAY OR MAY NOT BE
DOING, YOU HAVE SEEN SOME
INCREDIBLE RESILIENCE FROM THE
PEOPLE OF THE PHILIPPINES.
TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
I MEAN, I JUST KEEP THINKING
ABOUT THIS AND I CAN'T STOP
THINKING, I MEAN, THE STRENGTH
IT TAKES NOT JUST TO SURVIVE A
STORM, BUT THE STRENGTH IT TAKES
FOR A MOTHER TO SURVIVE THE
AFTERMATH OF THIS STORM, WHEN
SIX OF HER CHILDREN ARE DEAD,
WHEN SHE CAN'T FIND THREE OF
THEIR BODIES AND YOU KNOW, WHEN
A MOTHER CAN'T FIND WATER TO
GIVE TO HER THIRSTY CHILD.
I MEAN, THE STRENGTH THAT IT
TAKES, EVEN IN A GOOD DAY, TO
LIVE IN A SHACK AND DEAL WITH
THE INDIGNITIES THAT POVERTY
FORCES UPON PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE ARE INCREDIBLY
DIGNIFIED AND IN THE FACE OF
VERY LITTLE HELP ALL THIS PAST
WEEK, THEY HAVE BEEN STANDING
TALL WITH HUMOR, I MEAN, PEOPLE
LAUGHING, FINDING WAYS TO SMILE
EVEN AMIDST THE